er verstehe was geht ich hätte zwei
fragen an die erste frage kannst du mir
deine zunge dein album berühren und die
zweite frage wieder musstest du deiner
mutter überzeugen wir sind ein videos
mitspielt hat sie gleich ja gesagt oder
wollen sie erst mal im endspiel dann
gehört man frank verantwortlich man
sieht sie auf youtube ich muss jetzt
natürlich versuche ich weiß es nicht
mal wieder zum affen machen ist
letztlich kann sich unglaublich lange
arme und dünner aber habe
aber es können einige
die zweite frage war ja meine mutter ob
ich sie überzeugen musste beim ersten
mal habe wusste sie überhaupt nicht
worauf sie sich einlässt weiß ja nicht
erzählt habe dass ich das überhaupt
online stellen und dann hat sie ganz
tolle positive resonanzen bekommen und
dann hat sie das von allein und sie sagt
immer eigentlich eher nicht aber
ganz tief im inneren möchte sie es
eigentlich doch